hab ich dachte ich schicke euch ruft die
ganze zeit
[Musik]
aber weil haben ist luca um meine damen
und herren was sich unfassbar viele
menschen von euch leider gewünscht haben
ist dass meine freundin das übrigens
sehr schönes gefühl und ich werden heute
zusammen ford naidoos spielen man ja als
lama durch dass das hier bist du
versuchst zu hauen juli als erstes
schauen wir mal wo wir hinfliegen
ich würde sagen wir gehen zu tötet
direkt als nie viel los als ich würde
jetzt drückst du weh und guckst nach
ganz unten so dass da so schnell wie
möglich nach unten fliegst du bist
weiter oben wir gehen jetzt dahin wo du
den roten marca gesetzt hast ich bin tot
macht euch keinen spaß sie zu spielen
der derzeit voll den coolen regenbogen
haben
thomas summarum look zeigen hallo hallo
das war eine gute runde oder das war
jetzt das aufwärmen oder wohin ihr weg
gesperrt
was haben die denn hier gebaut
wir sind hier um gegner muss sie töten
um mein gott was sind das denn für euch
gute was machst du denn da versteckt
nicht du musst sie töten wie ich hier
sehe ich die spätere maustaste genauso
ja die abschieds die ab juli sehr gut
und noch mal und er nächste runde
ich lebte als weil die fresse du laden
eine frist und chips man hört sich so
heftig schmerzen zugehalten ok jule wir
gehen jetzt zu vettel fiel zog das ist
da unten das ist ein farmer land
ich habe mich wieder hinten sind auf
jeden fall auch noch andere leute
zapp den anderen neun das doch nicht war
okay oder was machst du bist weg sind
schnitzel so ein bisschen häuser vor
du kannst ja auch da hinten meine waffen
holen die liegen da herum
der kollege ist da ja noch bin ich zu
blöd wie du.de nachtleben haltende
trumpet das ist eigentlich mein
schienbein rom gewickelt wohin wollen
wir gehen
du darfst du dir aussuchen ich habe
getränk für dich ja fast und jetzt genau
jetzt ringgau für was tust du hier
runter gesprungen er dachte ich die
kiste
das hilft mir das und medicaid schule
komme hierhin kommt was willst du denn
machen
hey was sehen was gucken oben ist das ja
das ist total beschissene waffe
anzuschließen kommt man mit jetzt hier
kann man mit dem scheiß alpaka nähe ist
auch ein lama aber okay julia jetzt auf
nein aber ich dachte
so sind wir cool das ist müll oh mein
gott hier ist raketenwerfer hat ja so
save me juli gerade ins knie geschossen
du glaub ich ja alle für mich hat das
ihr gefunden ich habe den ort aus hier
gibt es auch so andere schächte hier
können wir auch mal reingehen und habe
durch das erinnert mich ein bisschen an
bord
kannst du die türen nicht noch mal
aufmachen ich hab ein paar schneemänner
gebaut wir können doch hier vorne durch
das portal neben durchlaufen war sind
nutzen wohnen war okay julias leben nur
noch 27 menschen das heißt wir haben
tatsächlich eigentlich eine relativ gute
chance das ding hier zu gewinnen ich bei
uns jetzt was komme ich bei uns jetzt
eine ganz ganz lange treppe wo wir sind
alt und wir springen und direkt
leertaste drücken nun fliegst du denn
hin hier wollte ich hier vorne steht
jetzt am theater kann zu drücken dann
sitzt du da drauf und ich geh jetzt aufs
andere kurz und jetzt können wir
irgendwohin fahren wir haben auch nitro
cool oder
[Musik]
dort hinten sind gegner da fahren wir
nicht hingefahren lass mal hier sind
drei kisten nägel stühle von irgendwo
schießen leute auf
ja lass uns mal verstecken irgendwo bist
du von dir hoch gelaufen
meine die treppe hier solche treppe
bauen und da sind leute das sind heute
mein gott oh mein gott der portier
heftig nein der war gut scheiße wie
viele kills hat der 4er das ok das nicht
so gut halo ist nur noch zehn übrig und
wir haben doch kein leben stimmt wir
sind hier wir sind glatt 6 ist echt gut
oder ja jetzt gewinnen wir oder kann
auch hier hingehen das ist ganz einfach
mal am besten jetzt schon mal den
falschen auf dem wasser landen ist
automatisch tot
okay wir sind jetzt hier an einem ort
angekommen der heißt lang junction das
ist eine müllhalde du willst du oh mein
gott da ist noch eine andere person
er hat mich tot du musst wieder regeln
scheiße was wir vor den rücken
geschossen
blödmann nur drei melden
juli
hallo ich musste noch melden mir fallen
da guck mal der hut vor den regenbogen
und der schwede fliegen
bist du cool land noch jemand unter oder
was machst du mal weggehen ich mache gar
nicht in die kiste gefunden
ja oh mein gott dann stand sie genau da
wo du das kaputt gemacht
das jetzt mal ein bisschen action action
machen was machst du so machst das haus
kaputt meine treppe bauen hast du denn
was zum weg springen dann auch noch
keine treppe aber du kannst ja mal sagen
wo du hingehen möchte sich e-mails genug
materialien
du hast anscheinend noch nicht genau
materialien ja ich hole ich bin kein
baum getroffen wurde achtung dieser
heftigkeit achtung achtung julia ich bin
tot
oh mann ich dachte ich schieße ich habe
mir gesucht die ganze zeit
also hätte ich dir ja umgebracht die
blödmänner oder mehr fähig mit zum user
wie dir zu spielen ich bin auf einmal
level 3 ich war vorher will 19
das ist ja dann anscheinend nicht so gut
60 mal ganz gut gegen die medien werfen
warum fakt ist zurück so aussehen
darunter ist ja so ein ganz kleines dorf
wollen wir daran einfach landen
sorry also jule hier ist tatsächlich
nahezu kein mensch gelandet das heißt
wir haben eigentlich gut chancen jetzt
die wirklich was reißen zu können
willst du was von mir haben hier das was
sie haben
komm zu mir ja warte hier ich habe
sachen für die hier auf der anderen
seite hier kommen ich hab mein google
hier hinten nein zurück und jetzt hier
bin ich das für dich duca ich will noch
ein bisschen spaß haben ja hier
wenn wir noch zeit bis das hier der
trailer macht zu sein
[Musik]
was machst du jetzt holst du dir runter
ja da müssen wir rein das ist ein wir
müssen jetzt beide in dieser schrift ich
bin durch du hast wie die die dreckigen
juni/juli da hinten ist action da siehst
du das wort da gehen wir nicht hin
juli wo bist du okay ich komm mit wir
sind die friedensstifter ok damit hier
in das haus rein wir verstecken uns
darin okay ich weiß auch nicht gerade in
die badewanne ein paar sekunden später
glich in der badewanne getötet das war
nicht sehr nett
du bist gemeint ich films mit dir
zusammen passen
juli erzielt du mit deinem kopf genau
auf das ende von diesem marker oder
julia sind auf jeden fall auch andere
leute muss ein bisschen vorsichtig sein
okay bringen die abschließenden schießen
vor mein gott nein die haben mich julie
du schaffst das paar ja der mutter nach
laden warst du mal unsere runden
zusammen er du bist halt immer früher
gestorben
ich würde auf jeden fall sagen du übst
nochmal in du mitspielt dann ist
vielleicht ein zwei leute noch
zusätzlich auf einen schießen weil du so
eine belastung bis aber das ist ja das
schöne am leben dass man jemanden zu
belehren
du bist ja auch noch relativ jungen halt
einfach dein maul
[Musik]
die